we've already talked quite a bit about
the idea that if look you if you have a
market
capitalist economy
that some that this will lead hopefully
to economic growth
economic
growth
but by definition a market economy will
have some folks who win more and some
folks who don't do as well and it's
going to you're also going to have
inequality
inequality so inequality is essentially
a fact of life of a market economy and
it's not necessarily something that you
just want to turn off because that might
also hurt economic growth and that
actually might make everyone better off
because the economic growth on a per
capita basis could also be benefiting
people who aren't in the top percentile
or decile or quartile not always but it
could be but with that thought in the
back of our minds let's actually think a
little bit more about inequality and how
and how it's measured and how it can be
tied to things like
capital and growth of income to capital
and returns on capital
so this right over here this is from
thomas piketty's book and that's what's
neat is he's made all of the charts of
his book available online
right over there
and this shows income inequality in the
united states between 1910 and 2010.
and what you see here he measures it by
the share of top decile in national
income so top decile is a top 10
so this point right over here tells us
that in 1910
the top 10 of earners
made a little over 40 of the national
income as we go into the late 20s that
approaches 50 percent at the top that
that the top 10 of earners were making
close to half of the national income and
then as we go through the great
depression and especially after world
war ii this drops down into the low 30
and then from the 1980s to the present
this has crept back up to the high 40
percent range so the top
decile the top 10 of earners are making
close to close to half of the national
income and let's just visualize how this
happens just numerically
so
let's imagine this is your economy in
year one
so this is your economy in year one and
actually let me copy and paste that i
think that'll be useful
so copy
all right and let's say that this is
the fraction i'll do it in orange that
is going to the top decile so let's say
it's roughly a third
in year one so this is the fraction
that's going to the top decile this is
one-third right over here so the way
that you have rising so on this chart
this would be kind of a 33.3
so it would be someplace around here so
we could pretend like where some date in
the 60s or 70s right over here
and now the way that you have
this chart moving up where you have the
top decile having a larger and larger
share of national income
is if this orange section grows faster
than this green section
so if for example this
this grew by 10
while this grew by 5
by five percent over time this orange
section is going to take a larger and
larger chunk of the green section now as
we saw in previous videos even if this
does happen and this is this is by
definition rising inequality there could
be a scenario where the other 90 are
still having a bigger pie and on a per
capita basis still might be able to be
better off
but the focus of this video is not that
the focus of the video is tying this
idea to the idea of
increasing returns on capital driving
this phenomenon driving inequality
income inequality
so as we've seen before
income and wealth are not the same thing
but wealth could be a proxy the more
wealth that you have you will have more
income from that wealth you will have
return on that capital so another way to
divide the economy
is instead of thinking of the top 10 of
earners and the other 90 of earners you
could think of how much of this income
goes to the owners of capital and how
much of it goes to the people who
provide the labor so it's more of a
labor capital split versus 90 you know
the bottom 90 top 10 percent split so
here we could think of
this section right over here and i'll
just make it a different so let's say
this is right over here this is how much
is going to owners of capital
to
capital to owners of of capital the
people who own the buildings the real
estate the resources and how much of
national income is going to labor so
this right over here
this right over here is going
is going to labor
now
the same a similar idea is look if this
blue section if this blue section
grows consistently grows faster than the
green pie than the green pie then the
percentage of income that goes to
capital is going to grow more and more
and more and because in capitalist
market economies capital is also not
evenly distributed mainly because income
is not evenly distributed because
capital is not evenly distributed that
this would essentially lead this as as
more and more income goes to capital and
that capital is disproportionately owned
by the upper decile of income or wealth
then you're going to it's essentially
going to drive this phenomenon right
over there now i want to be very clear
this
growth right over here you'll hear the
term return on capital in conjunction
with piketty's book where they compare
the return on capital to growth rates
and this growth right over here is not
the return on capital in order to know
the return on capital you have to know
how much you need to know the income
that the capital generated but you also
have to know the value of that capital
and here in this diagram all i know is
the income that the capital generated
but i don't know the value of that
capital so i can't calculate the return
on capital this growth that i'm showing
right over here maybe after a few years
this blue section grows to over here
while the green section while the pie
has grown something like this this
growth right over here you could view
this as the
growth
growth of income to capital which isn't
something you hear a lot about but this
growth right over here this growth maybe
this is plus five percent
for the total economy this is the g
that's often referred to this is the
total growth of the economy